[Music]
hey so it is good to be back on this
side of the pond that's right because
last week we were preempted for a
special coverage of King Charles III's
coronation yeah if you tuned in last
Saturday you got to see our coverage and
this week we wanted to give you a little
look behind the scenes
we're ready to go we are
what are you reading
Illustrated coordination Edition
coronation special
[Music]
because we are headed where to London
coronation
[Music]
and away we go nothing to layer
that would be me
we have our first um memorabilia small
t-shirts
posters oh
but I can't buy any of this now
the princess arrives do we have to
curtsy to him then
my two princesses in one place why are
we not Queens
[Music]
[Applause]
look at you you're ready I'm ready are
you ready I think so I think so Jamie
you ready I'm ready this is a traveling
crew
[Music]
but this is so cool that's not an
accident
this is a CBS News special report the
coronation of King Charles III today
Britain's new king will officially be
recognized as Monarch in front of about
2 000 guests King Charles and his wife
Camilla the queen consort are moments
away from leaving for today's ceremonies
and a huge crowd has gathered to watch
most of the king subjects and nearly all
of us around the world have never seen
the coronation of a British monarch the
last was Queen Elizabeth of course 70
years ago next month it is the king and
the queen consort in the Diamond Jubilee
State coach making their way now it is
an awesome spectacle it really is a
watch
Charles seems quite Serene yes he does
I come not to be served but to serve
[Applause]
king of kings and Lord of lords bless we
beseech thee this crown
God Save the King
the King has been crowned we are
watching the coronation procession the
Precision of this is absolutely
spectacular we are waiting for the
return of the newly crowned King Charles
and queen Camilla to the Palace
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
the reign of King Charles III begins
[Applause]
[Laughter]
unbelievable I I want to pinch myself I
don't even believe that we were there
you finally got your satmo field trip
you did
you know we all bonded so well there was
some bonding there was some bondage it
was really amazing and I gotta say the
carriages I know I've really obsessed
over them they looked like Disney Creeds
it was Unreal it really was like that
yeah like a Disney parade and we looked
kind of professional on camera
we call it off sometimes